so three questions here and i wonder if
you connected
the dots for why i gave you these three
questions we'll see
how we go in further integration we have
seen questions
like this actually back since extension
one days right it's a fairly
straightforward application
of the reverse chain rule do you have
any questions about it or is it
reasonably uncontroversial question one
question one's okay
uh one minus x cubed you can see it
doesn't take much twisting twisting and
turning
to get the derivative of one minus x
cubed within
the integrand it's just the classic old
uh stick in
a an appropriate constant coefficient
i've chosen
uh negative three just to go all the way
there and then off you go does that look
okay to you
yeah oh there you put a negative y into
the one minus x cubed you turn it into x
cubed minus one
could we put in a negative one into the
one minus x
cubed to turn it into x cubed minus one
that was the question
before i answer it does anyone have any
opinions
on that factoring out or putting in
a negative one in order to turn into x q
minus one thoughts
yeah so wait maybe i should ask a
question do you mean before or after
integration
uh after after so you're talking about
like after i'm done here at the bottom
yeah sure yeah so uh the short answer is
as anger points out
in this case doesn't really matter
totally fine i should point out
because it's a classic error to be made
in this case we sort of get lucky
you are actually not taking out a factor
of negative one you are actually taking
out
five factors of negative one which
happens to also be
negative one right uh because you can
see here right
when you're factoring that out if you
take out negative one you're taking out
negative one
to the five right and it's actually a
fairly common error to take out like oh
i see i see one factor if if of course
we ended up with an even
power you'd be in some trouble wouldn't
you okay yeah
that's true so being an odd function we
can actually just say
i can use uh rotational symmetry here
by substituting in a negative x instead
and then slapping a minus sign out the
front that would be equivalent
okay with that all right well done let's
have a look at number two you looked at
these
kinds of questions on tuesday in fact
you might even have a look at how to
look at this exact
question because i pulled it out of 4b
uh there are multiple ways to go about
this but
this is a method i'm pretty sure mrs
lee's showed you right what have i done
could you explain to me what the working
looks like
says what are you thinking when you have
a look at that um
why you changed actually about four
into different constants so that you
have the denominator
on top yeah yeah very good so what i'm
trying to do
is to split apart this relatively uh
concise fraction into something that
looks much messier
you know if you have a look down to you
know these two lines here it's like wow
i've got all these different things
flying around but why is it advantageous
to me to have them
separately it's simpler
this is our segue into uh today's
lessons it's simpler
for the purposes of integration does
that make sense like i can look at each
of those individual pieces
and i'm good to go all right
there's your integral and then lastly
you might think this one is a bit of a
uh
what's that doing there why does that
belong
did i differentiate correctly you happy
with that
okay now this is actually the question i
want to fixate on question two and
question three
there's a theme there's a connection
between questions two and three that i
wonder
if you notice who left their answer like
this
hands up put your hands up a bit higher
i want to see because and i also want to
see
make sure you can see the rest of the
class did anyone who didn't then
didn't get to the answer okay so i'm
asking did anyone factorize this
no one factorized okay so my question is
why not factorizing is a thing that we
routinely do
especially with derivatives why didn't
you factorize it
couldn't be bothered you asked me to
differentiate i differentiated then i
flipped the table and i walked off okay
that's a fair answer does anyone want to
give me uh i mean i
and in honesty i've told you
mathematicians are lazy so that is
totally legitimate
is there any more like like proper
answer
we could give are you takers apart from
laziness morgan
um i'm guessing in integration because
we have to
see the connection between the primitive
function with the
differentiated function is for example
the differentiated functions on top
and the primitive functions on the
bottom then we can immediately do for
example
to get the answer and we can see the
differentiated function more clearly
okay very good
so and you're noticing morgan the theme
that i sort of tried to connect between
questions two and three right what i was
trying to say was
sometimes you can look at the same
object but depending on the form that
you've got it in
it makes it easier or harder to do
certain things
do you agree in this case you know the
topic we look at it's integration
in a question like this not a rhetorical
question sometimes this expanded form is
the one you want
and other times the factorized form is
the one
you want can someone give me an example
where even though you're like i'm lazy i
don't want to do this
but under certain circumstances you say
actually factorizing is pretty much the
only way
to go xiao what would you say uh when
you're trying to find like
points of like a turning point
okay equating dx equals zero okay so
two things number one yes if i want to
locate
stationary points then it is much easier
to read off the location of those the x
values anyway
if it's factorized okay my second point
is
and i'm only going to pick this up for
you guys because especially like now
because you're an extension two class
d dx what is ddx d on dx
maybe you haven't been actually
introduced to this language it's what we
call a differential
operator it does things like times plus
minus divides it's an operation right
d on dx is not an object it's not a
thing that you can
act upon it's an action right it is an
action itself
so i think we mean d on dx of this
function i can set that to zero
d on dx is not an object that can equal
to zero
makes sense minor point of language but
important morgan were you gonna say
something different or similar
yeah okay so under such circumstances if
i wanted to locate stationary points
go and factorize it's a bit of a pain
it's not monic but you can do it right
can someone by contrast tell me what
circumstances will make this
better to leave it what would you might
what might you want to do next that this
is a more
appropriate form you guys have given me
some great suggestions but i reckon the
rest of the class should know
this is advanced this is not even
extension one come on have a think
second yes second derivative explain a
little more anger what do you mean
um if you want to differentiate it
further towards like another step
then it's much easier to just leave it
in that form because you have
the individual terms instead of like
doing it in effective form because then
you would have to use the chain rule
pretty close if i factorized and i found
my stationary points and all that kind
of thing
if i then take that factorized form in
order to
then go to the next step suppose say
determining the nature of those
stationary points
you're going to have yeah you caught it
right you're going to have some version
of this right
i can't actually remember what the exact
factors are it's something something
like that right
and then if i differentiate it in this
form you're like ah product rule
i mean we're pretty good at the product
rule but why not just use
this form which doesn't require any
product rule chain rule question rule
you just go term by term does this make
sense